ciao ciao ragazzi su forgotten se ci
sarà un cazzo di motivo se questi cui
nel solo di calcio è questo e camminare
lento e questo è camminare faster a
posto a quadri si è accorto che ha messo
la camminata lenta pasino scusa area ah
ecco e non si sa c'è un nucleo che si
escludendo non benissimo non benissimo
ragazzi va più veloce da crucciato il
che è pazzesco cioè in cammino dal
tabacchino c'è un computer ma sblocca la
zona slogan slogan siamo tutti male
qualcosa è arrivata dall altro mondo chi
è dentro di noi
sì sì arrivederci allora musona che devo
camminare da sdraiato praticamente cos'è
sta roba è che tipo è cosa di crash
bandicoot centrodentro è a posto come
cazzo soul finito poi botta il turner
dimenticati istituì nel ci sarà
veramente un motivo lo scopriamo sono
entrati in un altro mondo corretto cioè
presente quel portale da un portale di
collegamento verso un altro mondo negli
altri mondi anno le ruggini che gli
ascensori tutte e due le cose sia
accessori perugini non è male non è male
non è male ma no ma un cazzo cioè se non
avete le luci quindi un po male lo è
devo andare
si apre meno ma non hanno le porte che
si apre in automatico anno le candele
nell'altro mondo mi fa piacere mi fa
molto piacere la stessa roba capitolo 2
fordo attenta nel cimitero
ok alcune porte sono chiuse da delle
forze estranee rompi sigilli per
sbloccarle a questo ha aperto ok
beh almeno allegro giorno sto cercando
lì i sigilli
non so se avete i sigilli qua passera
qualcuno 100 100
e vabbè la madonna se mi sputa ora io me
ne vado e cioè proprio mi alzo lascio il
gameplay ne vado giocate voi cioè io ve
lo dico eh no perché vedo ragnatele
quando vedrai a tenere i giochi mi
prendete sempre per il no ragazzi dai
per favore ve lo chiedo per cortesia non
mi fate uscire verrà anni perduti cazzo
devo andare prodotti indietro tanto
cammino solo ci mette un'ora camminata
non facendo da strada
ok ancora la mia tele ma va bene va bene
succede nulla
porca [ __ ] porca [ __ ] o che possa
posto posso o un bello la chiave ho
trovato la chiavetta i ragni non sono
aprire le porte con la chiave quindi
dovrebbe dovrebbe dovrebbe essere al
sicuro non lo so sono questi qua sono
sempre più né dimenticati anche dai
ragni spese beh è tutto a posto
e tutto molto meglio di quello che
pensavo molto meglio di quanto pensassi
però devo andare di qua io lo zio devo
andare qua qua prefetto perfetto sono
passato non so come ma sono passato va
bene ciao
porca [ __ ] devo trovare una chiave pure
l'ho presa a ciò la via di acilia mia
faccio per correre più veloce mai mai
mai mai mai quadri let's go non ha preso
non ha preso il mio chiudi apporto
perfetto
ciao
salve
non ho voce mi scusi non posso urlare
però vedo che lei che mi attende ma che
cazzo ne fu santamaria giorno
vabbè arrivederci ei no no tube
benissimo va bene la cosa sia la cosa
più bella che ho visto il suo gioco
guarda sto più brutte le candele però
sicuro posso strisciare anch'io la somma
vabbè dai ne vado avanti o si sa mai
l'affare share porca [ __ ] merda
macché comportati one è questa c'è
questo qua l'hanno messo qua qua quali
hanno messo mi sono cagato nel cervello
proprio signori calmi calmiamoci perché
qua è un attimo e sta sfuggendo di mano
a situazioni come cacchio faccio ad
andare avanti di quart ma non labyrinth
ora non si capisce niente meno mai certi
jolie che se torna indietro so che sotto
l'adige dove c'è lui
juicy giro cioè sigillo l'ho trovato uno
va a mons
sì sì eccolo qua a bosh 18
resta chiusa c'è una chiave da shanghai
giro più di tutto chiuso
checa io faccio che cazzo
oddio santo benedetto che ansia
eccola ma va a cagare ma una saporta
porca [ __ ] dai ragazzi dai dai per
favore non mi fate questo non fate
questo non lo fate non lo fate
basta dunque loro 8 si girano ok si è
tolta la porta consigli non mi ricordo
quale fosse questa mi cosa da questo
questa
ok non era quella per fare l'unica che
si apre bene le slot mattone che il
gioco di death of despair il patto della
disperazione non uso presente spyer
teoria della disperazione la
disperazione di sparisce barbato dado
veloci incrociato e ridicola sta cosa ne
vado ma chi
sento rumori chic rumori orribili all
ricki l'anno ragazzi vi prego fatemi
fare
fatevi prendere una tisana cena e la
disamina tu quello una presa troppo il
design a codigoro della roba ok molto
lungo corridoio non si vede niente mi si
stava pure spegnendo la torcia laga
porca trota il nome di nulla o che si è
accettato scusi ma vaff e quello debole
da quello che vuoi ma che cassetti ma
chi ti caga ma tutti targa tipica gac i
sei chi ti conosce
ma vai via questa romeo vero polmoni
extralarge va bene sembra un buco di
coupé simpatico ma devo chiudere qualche
giorno quarto brutto suo posto c'è
praticamente in confronto silent hill e
mirabilandia c'è veramente ma ragazzi ma
di che parliamo
va tutto bene se non ci fossero secante
non vedrai un caso la torcia che
illumina meno della storia questo qua ha
dormito un po troppo però vabbè finché
non mi compare nessuno
ma io che cazzo parlo ma io perché fa
perché parlo nella me perché mi hanno
dato la lingua perché creare cosa era il
primo ha bisogno di forgotten tale io
chiudo qua perché è molto molto
ansiolitico e ci saranno ben due episodi
spero vi piaccia perché il secondo sarà
ancora peggio nel senso di cose che
succede però il previsto è piaciuto
questo mi piace che bisogna vedere
situata sotto 20 si chiede ero cda come
sempre hanno proseguito i ragazzi
[Musica]